hey youtubers is Charlie so my friends
on the geek and sundry Channel are doing
a brand new show that I'm really excited
about so I'm gonna be doing some bonus
videos for that it's called arcade arms
and it's basically involves them making
video game weapons and doing cool stuff
with them you know mostly smashing
things I think their permit for human
testing is still pending so this video
is just gonna be a breakdown of some of
the weapons they're gonna be making and
when they're gonna start posting
episodes and the bonus videos that I'm
gonna be doing for it be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I'll also have links down in the
description for all the important stuff
the show itself is actually hosted by
Nika Harper if you haven't seen her
before she's been doing a lot of stuff
with Keegan sundry for the past couple
years like wordplay she also did a
league of Legends show on their official
channel called summoner showcase I think
she's really good I really enjoy her
enthusiasm for smashing stuff with giant
weapons because all the weapons are
based on really big video games they
also did a bunch of cool interviews with
the people that actually made the games
so like for instance in the first
episode they have the lead lore master
for Elder Scrolls online talked about
the story behind the weapon they make so
a big part of the show is talking about
the lore behind a lot of the weapons and
then actually going ahead and making
those weapons in real life so here are
the top 5 things that I'm really excited
about saying number 5 learning how they
actually make the weapons dismissed that
they pick to make everything talked a
lot about the practical aspects of the
weapons and why they have specific
features so like for instance on a mace
you know there's a reason why each side
is mirrored so they talk a lot about
that number for the locations they
actually had to travel quite a bit to
find each of these people to make the
weapons the skill it takes to make
weapons like these is really rare so
they actually had to travel all over the
place just to give you an idea how far
they had to travel they actually had to
go all the way to New Brunswick Canada
to find someone to make the weapon from
their first episode number 3 learning
the lore behind the weapons if you've
seen some of my other videos you know I
like to research mythology a lot they
talked to a lot of the people at each of
the game companies about the stories
behind the weapons it's like learning
about Oathkeeper in Game of Thrones from
george RR martin himself number 2
learning some of the cool
behind-the-scenes facts about creating
the lore for the games so in addition to
talking about the weapons in the games
they actually got a lot of cool
behind-the-scenes details about you know
why the designers made certain story
choices you'd be surprised at the amount
of time that game developers spent
creating lore around certain weapons and
characters and why they make certain
choices
and the number one thing that I'm
looking forward to and you should be too
is watching them actually play with a
weapons watching them use them they went
to a lot of LARP societies to learn
about you know say how a giant mace
would be used in real battle and you
know why you choose that instead of
another weapon like a sword then they
take it one step further and just smash
the hell out of stuff which is just
awesome the mace they made is actually
like 35 pounds which is more than enough
to crush someone's skull even if they're
wearing plate armor so here's the
details about when the show is gonna
start and where you can watch it and
what each of the episodes are gonna be
which weapons are going to be doing so
all the episodes will be on geek and
sundry's youtube channel the first one
will be Molag Bal's mace from elder
scrolls online then two weeks after that
will be the gale bolt from final fantasy
realm reborn and the third episode will
be Zelda's hero boat from Legend of
Zelda
that'll aired June 10th so remember new
episodes every two weeks right now
they've only announced those three
episodes but if you guys make it big
enough stink and bug them enough I'm
sure they'll think about making some
more so for the bonus videos that I'm
going to be doing I'll be talking mostly
about the characters and the lore behind
the weapons in the games that they're
going to be using so right now let's
talk a little bit about Elder Scrolls
online which is the basis of the first
episode so in case you haven't been
playing it Elder Scrolls online is like
the brand new MMO based on like the
Skyrim Dragonborn universe so think of
it as like you know a Skyrim MMO it's
been out on PC since April but it's
coming to Xbox one and ps4 later this
year if you're a console gamer the
weapon they're making in that first
episode is the mace of Molag Bal so
let's break him down just a little bit
he's one of the sixteen Daedric princes
and currently he is the main villain of
the MMO he was also a big part of the
Skyrim Dragonborn DLC and he appeared in
Oakland but for the purposes of this
video let's just stick to the MMO so if
you're not familiar with them the
Daedric princes in the scope of the
Elder Scrolls universe are basically
like really powerful gods they each have
their own plane of existence in the game
they are associated with artifacts and
super weapons that you can obtain you
know via quests like Moloch Balls mace
they're basically like raid quality
items with like mega mega bonuses Molag
is mostly like a harvester of souls part
of the quest back in Skyrim you had to
complete to get his mace involved
convincing someone to sacrifice their
soul to him
obviously an MMO you'll have to take him
down in rate to get that mace though if
you haven't played his quest through in
Skyrim it's one of those alignment ones
that takes you down this really dark
road so if you like playing evil
characters and you don't want to play
the MMO then just do the Skyrim quest
playing evil characters is a lot of fun
quicks I know - one of the first big
video games that took you down separate
paths you know based on quest chases in
alignment was Knights of the Old
Republic
it was always really really fun to play
reven is a super dark Jedi they get way
better cutscenes in the new MMO they
actually recast the voice actor so it's
Malcolm McDowell doing the voice which
is freaking awesome he plays some of the
best evil video game characters the mace
itself actually has a lot of vampiric
qualities whenever you equip it in the
game and you can't gem it and you know
improve it just a little bit but you
have to max out blacksmithing before you
can do it so now let's talk a little bit
about the MMO specifically right now
bullet ball is basically the main
villain but future expansions are
probably going to add lore from the
other Daedric princes the game actually
does this interesting thing with player
resurrection and makes it like a main
conceit of the game as an Moloch ball
has basically stolen your soul so you
keep getting resurrected because you
can't die as you play through the game
you basically try to get your soul back
so I guess you can die for a final time
right now there's three playable
factions and nine different races so
there's a little bit more choice for
people who are getting burnt out on
Warcraft Plus no matter which class you
choose DPS melee caster you can actually
still tweak armor and weapon skills so
you could be a caster that wears plate
that's actually a fantasy I've had in
the past but the only bummer thing about
the MMO right now is that because of the
era it takes place in the lore
there's no dragons but that doesn't mean
they won't add them in a future
expansion so I'll be doing a couple more
bonus videos you know specific to the
games and the weapons that they're going
to be doing on the show feature to
subscribe to get everything
there's also links for their actual show
in the description - the first episode
premieres next week on Tuesday on ikan
sundries youtube channel if there is a
special weapons that you think that they
should do in a future episode just leave
suggestions in the comments and if you
want to see me do more video game lore
videos just let me know I might move
some of those to my bonus gaming channel
just because that's where all my
gameplay videos going like I said I
really enjoyed doing a lot of research
for lore so let me know if you want to
see more videos like this right now you
can click
to learn more about arcade arms on geek
and sundry's channel and you can click
here to see more of my bonus videos for
it I'll have the annotations as soon as
I post it my next one will probably post
on Tuesday thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you